IS LOOK DOWN. THERE'S THE
NUMBER 16 STITCHES FOR DE
VINCENT SPRIGS. THE RAMS
ISSUED A STATEMENT. WE'RE
REGARDING AARON DONALD WE'RE
COLLECTING MORE INFORMATION
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME, BUT THE RAMS THINK
DOESN'T MATTER. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT FALLS WITHIN
THE EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION OF
THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE
UNDER THE PERSONAL CONDUCT
POLICY. THE RAMS CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT. HE'S NOT
AT WORK. IT'S THE OFFSEASON.
THIS IS WHERE THE NFL HAS THE
ABILITY TO TAKE ACTION AND WE
KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE THE NFL
ONLY HAS THE POWER TO DO
WHATEVER IT WANTS TO DO IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS, BUT IF
IS SOME FINDING THAT AARON
DONALD DID THIS HE'S GOT TO
WORRY ABOUT SOME SORT OF
SIMPLE THE PHOTO OF THE EYE
SWOLLEN SHUT RHONDA VINCENT
SPRIGS AND IF THERE WAS A
BROKEN ARM SUFFERED AT THE
HANDS OF AARON DONALD THESE
ARE THESE ARE SERIOUS MATTERS,
YOU KNOW GUYS
WHEN THEY GROW UP SOMETIMES
THEY DON'T REALIZE YOU CAN'T
GET IN A FIGHT LIKE IT USED
TO BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE A
GROWN MAN, YOU'RE GOING TO
INFLICT SERIOUS HARM ON THE
OTHER PERSON AND YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
CRIMINALLY POTENTIALLY AND
CIVILLY FOR ANY INJURIES THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL SUFFER NO,
RIGHT. I MEAN, I MEAN THAT
THAT IS I THINK SOMETIMES
WHAT GETS LOST IN TRANSLATION
WITH FOOTBALL PLAYERS. THEY
STILL HAVE THIS MINDSET OF
LIKE I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
COLLEGE LIKE YOUNG CRAZY
ATHLETE AND YOU FORGET LIKE
KNOW YOU'RE A GROWN MAN WITH
LIKE A LOT AT STAKE AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE DEPENDING ON
YOU. DEFINITELY. I MEAN, HEY,
WHAT'S THE OLD SAYING LIKE,
NOTHING GOOD HAPPENS AFTER 11
P.M. I MEAN, ISN'T THAT THE
OLD SAYING THERE? I DON'T
YOU WANT TO MESS WITH ON ARON
EARTH LIKE WHEN IT COMES TO 3
A.M. OR 4 A.M. IN THE
MORNING? I DON'T KNOW WHAT
AND SO IT'S DANGER OR ANY
OTHER OUR THE DOOR ANY HOUR
OF THE DAY, RIGHT? I MEAN
GOSH, HE IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
WHERE YOU JUST BE LIKE NO,
I'LL I'D RATHER GET PUNCHED
BY MIKE TYSON AND DEAL WITH
THIS GUY. I MEAN IT'S A
DIFFERENT ANIMAL ALTOGETHER.
BUT YEAH SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS
AND AARON DONALD COULD BE IN
TROUBLE. BUT WHEN YOU ARE
AARON DONALD AND YOU HAVE
THAT KIND OF RAW PHYSICAL
POWER AT YOUR DISPOSAL
BECOMES EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
TO EXERCISE RESTRAINT
AND AT ALL TIMES, I REMEMBER
THAT YOU KNOW, YOU USED TO
SAY IN THE MOVIES BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES HAVEN'T HEARD THIS
LINE IN A LONG TIME, BUT
SOMEONE WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW,
MY HANDS ARE REGISTERED AS
LETHAL WEAPONS. AND THERE WAS
THIS SENSE THAT BOXERS AREN'T
ALLOWED TO GET IN FIGHTS
BECAUSE THEY MAY KILL
SOMEBODY RIGHT AARON DONALD
ISN'T A BOXER BUT HE MAY KILL
SOMEBODY LITERALLY SO LOOK
WE LIVE IN THE AGE OF
EVERYONE WALKING AROUND WITH
THE CELL PHONE DEVICE. I
ASSUME THEY'LL BE VIDEO
SOMEWHERE. IT HAPPENED OUT ON
THE STREET SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS ARE EVERYWHERE
SOMEWHERE SOMEHOW WILL
ABLE TO EITHER SHOW THAT
DONALD WAS INVOLVED IN THIS
FIGHT OR THAT HE WASN'T AND
IF HE WAS THE SOONER HE MAKES
RIGHT WITH DE VINCENNES
SPRIGS THE BETTER OFF. HE'S
GOING TO BE BOTH IN THE EYES
OF THE CRIMINAL AUTHORITIES.
YEAH, AND THE COURT OF ROGER
GOODELL AT 3:45 PARK AVENUE,
AND IT'S JUST ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU NEVER KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR THE
NEWS. OH, THERE'S A PLAYER
EVEN A STAR PLAYER EVEN A
STAR HALL OF FAMER ONE OF THE
BEST PLAYERS IN THE LEAGUE IF
THIS HAPPENS THE AND THIS IS
MY I JUST HOPE THAT THE
JUSTICE IS METED OUT. YEAH
THE SAME WAY IT WOULD BE FOR
ANYBODY ELSE THAT
AT THE LEAGUE DOESN'T GET
CAUGHT UP IN THE IDEA THAT
AARON DONALD'S A STAR PLAYER.
I HOPE THEY DON'T GO HARDER
ON HIM BECAUSE OF IT AND I
HOPE THEY DON'T GO EASIER.
SOMETIMES THEY GO HARDER ON
THE BIG STAR BECAUSE IT'S A
BIGGER STORY WHEN IT'S A STAR
VERSUS SOME BACKUP THAT
NOBODY CARES ABOUT. NO, I
KNOW I MEAN LISTEN, WE WILL
SEE HOW THE I DON'T WANT TO
MAKE ANY JUDGMENTS EITHER.
BUT I MEAN, I'VE BEEN AROUND
AARON DONALD A FEW TIMES, YOU
KNOW, THEY DON'T REALLY GET
ANY NICER THAN THE GUY
ALTOGETHER. I HAVE A HARD
TIME THINKING, YOU KNOW AGAIN
THAT HE WAS LIKE GOING AROUND
LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY TO BEAT
UP OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
YOU KNOW, AND I CAN
HONESTLY SAY EVEN FOR A GUY
LIKE AARON DONALD I'LL SAY
THIS STORY. HE MIGHT NOT EVEN
BE HAPPY BUT LIKE PEOPLE CAN
BE STUPID AT THAT TIME OF THE
DAY. THEY CAN THEY COULD HAVE
A LOT OF LIQUID COURAGE AND
DO A LOT OF DUMB CRAP. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW
THAT I MEAN I WAS WITH A
TEAMMATE OF MINE SEAN RODDERS
YOU REMEMBER SEAN ROGERS THE
NOSE TACKLE BACK IN THE DAY
MIKE. HE'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HUMANS EVER. I MEAN WE WERE
OUT IN ONE NIGHT AND HE
SHOWED RESTRAINT THIS GUY
KEPT BOTHERING THEM AND
BOTHERING HIM BOTHER HIM AND
HE SHOWED RESTRAINT THE
WHOLE NIGHT THE WHOLE NIGHT
HOLD THAT THE GUY FINALLY
JUST WOULDN'T GIVE UP AND
STARTED TILL I GET REALLY
CONFRONTATIONAL HAS AND THEN
HIS FACE AND HE WAS YOU KNOW
COMPLETED DISRESPECT TO THE
GUY. WELL, SEAN ROGERS, YOU
KNOW AT ALL 340. HE TOOK HIS
LEFT HAND BACK AND COCK BACK
AND KNOCK THE GUY ACROSS THE
ROOM LIKE IT WAS A CARTOON,
YOU KNOW, AND I WANT TO GO
LIKE, YEAH. I WISH HE
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT. BUT
I ALSO WANT TO GO LIKE DAMN.
WAS HE SUPPOSED TO DO? THIS
GUY WAS GONNA YOU KNOW, CAUSE
A PROBLEM NO MATTER WHAT SO
AGAIN THIS TIME.
SAY LET'S NOT JUDGE TOO.
HARSHLY. WE'LL SEE WHERE IT
GOES. YEAH DISENGAGE IN LIE.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SELF DEFENSE AND THIS GUY IS
JUST I KNOW PAIN IN MY ASS.
I'M GONNA PUNCH HIM ACROSS
THE ROOM LIKE IT'S A CARTOON
I GET YOU DISENGAGE AND LEAVE